of little brother is now listening
um there's a lot of little brothers
running around here uh
dr david brim it's always a pleasure to
speak to you
it's greater pleasure to see you uh
it's a wonderful delight to learn from
you
and uh furthermore it's just uh it's
great to
share these conversations with our
lovely audience at the
arthur c clarke center for human
imaginations into the impossible podcast
welcome good doctor all right and uh
glad to
see you brian and um by proxy
talk to your uh elite
audience of um smarty pants
or i guess we should say smarty all
garments
so i wanted to start off with something
provocative that i saw
on uh on contrary brynn david's website
uh davidbrin.net i think is it
davidbrind.net
well davidbrynn.com is my um
website yeah and then contrary brynn
is my um is my uh blog
yeah so i saw a couple of things one i
think is pertinent
to the situation that we are in i want
to
get an update from you on our from our
last conversation in april
when things involving a certain beer
named virus were
just developing and we were just
entering quarantine by the way david you
i'm sure know the origin of the word
quarantine right what it means
um i i i'm sure i knew it at some point
it means oh yeah four forty 40 yes i'm
sorry 14.
40 yeah so originally you would 14 days
yes 14 days you were supposed to be stay
on the ship before you were allowed or
shore
and that's like so we're we're on our
10th quarantine
uh 10th 14 day period maybe 11th
how have you adjusted to it have you
seen any
green shoots or are they all concrete
bunkers well i mean we've seen that some
states like new york have handled things
very similarly
and they had a worse strain of the virus
but new york handled things very much
like the western europeans have
and that is that they um developed a
sense of community they shut down
they everybody wore masks and and within
maybe two quarantine periods what had
looked like a
train wreck in new york turned out to be
a model for the nation
the problem is that we were forced to be
50 nations and many of them
um decided that they
um knew better than the experts so
the the united states is a um
is a hodgepodge of um
well arguments for brexit actually
because the fact is that we have no
borders
between these states and so they can't
be separate
experiments that was the idea behind
federalism was separate experiments but
the notion was that a disastrous
experiment in one state
will not necessarily affect its
neighbors well we've learned that that's
not true
yeah i'm supposed to have uh ben shapiro
on my
podcast not too uh long from now and
connection to his new book how to
destroy america in three easy steps
which i received a pre-publication copy
of
kindly from his people and that book
makes an argument that america
could be disintegrated as he calls it uh
and i know your politics are very
different from his we take all people on
this podcast and we do not get into
politics specifically
but one thing he talks about is very
much in consonant with what you just
said
and in my critic critique of the book i
basically lay out a couple of different
scenarios where
it's uh the conclusion comes down to the
fact that
federalism is not a law of nature it is
not something that is guaranteed
for our country to remain these 50
unified
states and i wonder if if i had asked
you
in february uh is the united states
going to
endure for another 254 years uh 44 years
what would you have said the odds would
be of that remaining 50 contiguous 50
united states
and what do you think the odds are now
that's that well i
it hasn't changed that much because back
then before
code that i knew we were under attack
the
um explain that sorry under attack all
right look
uh big picture perspective are us that's
what i do
you know when i do science fiction i do
big picture perspective of the future
but
most science fiction authors it's
believed that science fiction was badly
named it should have been called
speculative history
yes or thought experiments yeah right
because science
per se only 10 of science fiction
authors are scientifically trained as i
am i got my doctorate
where you now work at icsd proud son of
uc
similar similar field the um
only maybe 10 of us are scientifically
trained and and
bring as much science in as i do but all
of us are imbued with history which is
the
great tragic story it is the great story
of
millions upon millions of our ancestors
trying their best
and with with just horrifically stupid
dumb ideas in their heads
and implementing them and sometimes they
move things a bit forward
and we are the beneficiaries of all of
that but
one great plague infested human history
and that was a human's propensity for
delusion
we're all diluted science gave us tools
like the magic incantation i should say
the holy incantation of science
that we are all taught to recite which
is i might be
wrong let's find out now that
could should be the incantation of all
maturity
especially something that all males
should recite yes
but even that catechism
in science only lets us find maybe half
our errors
because we're delusional the great
discovery that we made in the few
enlightenment experiments
periclean athens da vinci's florence
and this 250-year experiment that we've
been trying
has been
letting rulers rule from the top down
allows them just to nurse their
delusions yeah and they make horrible
mistakes and with this litany of
mistakes is what we call history
um no civil no combination of
civilizations across 6 000 years have
been as successful as we have been
right and yet there is a cult spreading
across
both wings of the political axis but one
considerably more than the other
that um
that we should return to a pyramidal
type uh uh futile
uh based on inheritance and and and
and or race and fitness right and
societies were never as successful as
ours
never anywhere near close so this
experiment that we're
engaging in now vastly more successful
than periclean athens or da vinci's
florence
the civil war was a really gruesome one
but it was phase four
you have to go back to 1778 when
cornwallis came south
to the american south and found a great
many more royalists
and tories there and it's the same
basic division um
where just a lot of americans have
different dreams
and that reminds me of a quote that you
or a topic that you briefly
addressed on your on your blog uh that
also involves a multiple
of the number two as does uh as does
your eight phases of the civil war and
that's called the fourth turning
and i have not read this book i've seen
this book
i have been intrigued by this book i
have
connections to the one of the two
authors strauss and howe
one of them is deceased unfortunately
the other one is alive i'm hoping to
have him on the podcast someday
of course i'll have to learn his name by
then uh but i know you've spoken with
some
uh amusement uh perhaps that's to
light a word uh but can you talk a
little bit about that book and why it so
innervates you well the
again big picture perspective if you
look across history there have been
romantics
uh and left and right is not a sacred
thing locked in stone
uh most people on the left and most
people on the right do not
do not map onto what used to be called
left or right either in the french
assembly of 1789 when it got started
or the old notions of marxism
uh for instance um marketing market
capitalism
all the metrics fiscal responsibility
entrepreneurship
all of these things do better under
democrats
so go figure but what we loosely call
left and right
are two romanticisms and what really
really
is common among them is this
almost all people who have called
themselves leftists believe in a
teleology of history that is
teleology means history is foreordained
and that teleology is upward with
a lot of violence a revolution and all
of that if you're a leninist
or a maoist but it has a purpose it has
a
endpoint an evolutionary that's right
and which makes them much more like
christians
yeah now the right
has a tendency to also believe in
teleology but it's cyclical
um and so they tend to believe in rise
and fall rise and fall
civilizations get old they get lazy they
get
there's something called the titler uh
sequence
tyt you can look that up and my name or
look down below where brian will give
you a link to my
uh article about this where the right
people on the extreme right really
really cling to this notion of cyclical
history
that and and this is why why those who
called nazism
a a phenomenon of the left
this is the fundamental rejection of
that notion because
while stalin was a murderous horrible
person
he murdered for a progressive cause
that was he thought was climbing upward
hitler and the nazis believed that ice
moons came
regularly and caused everything to go
through the same cycle over and over
again now that leads us to straus
somehow
strausen howe's uh magical incantation
is the fourth
turning and that is that every 80 years
every
four generations perfectly rigidly timed
20 years each have four different
personalities
and these personalities lead them to
raise their kids
in different ways so that they will have
the next personality
and every fourth uh every third turning
wasteful lazy self-righteous
indignant generation causes a crisis
that their kids have to clean up and the
cleanup first cleanup was the american
revolution the second one
four score years later was um
the civil war phase four i call it
the next one was world war ii and now
we're 80 years after that and
the new hero generation has to clean up
that mess
well it's an alluring tale
i write alluring tales i recognize a
magical incantation that is meant to
entertain
draw people in and have them feel it's
plausible beat any of my novels and i
promise you
i promise you out guys out there you
will be
entranced and you will fail to feed the
cat you'll fail to get your work done
because i'm good at it i recognize
masters
strauss and howe did the same damn thing
they made a magical incantation and
boy does it read plausible yes and it is
gibbering loony
it has attracted attention on many
fronts and again i didn't you didn't
know i was going to ask you about this
but
um since you mentioned this this odd
octet multiple
of of two i i couldn't resist so
let's move on from there to something
much less provocative in some sense but
more provocative
to others of us who are of the nerdy
persuasion
and that involves uh so-called theories
of everything
as you know uh i've partnered with pbs
space time studios matt o'dowd and his
team
uh along with the uh friends of the
arthur c clarke center
and great show great show thank you yeah
it was
several good shows thank you yeah we put
out two shows so far
and we're hoping to get input from
people like you people in the audience
please send us
uh comments uh on on the videos and let
us know who you think we should
uh involve next because this is the
100th anniversary
of the very famous great debate
so-called the great debate
and in my book losing the nobel prize
obliterary plug here i don't know do i
have a copy here i've got existence here
but i don't know if i have uh my own
book here
uh that shows you the high esteem in
which i hold david anyway
uh i talk about the fact that we've
actually had multiple great debates
starting with galileo and probably even
before
the notion of the centrality of human
beings the earth
space and time itself being centered on
us has evolved from
thinking the earth is the center to the
sun as the center to the galaxy is the
center
to the universe is all there is to the
multiverse
must exist and now we find this
confluence of the very biggest things in
the universe namely the universe itself
possibly the multiverse
with the very smallest things in the
universe the quantum
realm of particles forces fields
and the quest to unify the very big and
the very small goes through what are
called theories of
everything and there's been a um a a
a very flourishing a renaissance if you
will
of new theories of everything from your
friend and mine stephen wolfram
to eric weinstein who's become a good
friend of the show
to garrett lisey and many other people
have come up with
novel ideas for how the universe is
large in scale and small scale can play
nice
first of all i want to ask you are these
important questions why should
uh jane uh bag of donuts out in el cajon
you know our standard listener why
should she care about such
minutia well she should care because
it's
extremely cool to have a civilization
that cares
that has built the prosperity
so that it's not just a few high priests
or monks
living their cauterized uh neutered
lives in some monastery who are
arguing about angels dancing on the head
of a pen
but instead are convoking these angels
in wonderful cathedrals of science
where we smash nature and say where
god are you here are you here are you
here
you know you don't have to be an atheist
in order to
be impudent now you can be a person who
has religious faith
and yet you believe that it was set up
for us to chase him down or her down
and you hear the giggles in the corners
as we shine light into corners that
no one's ever seen before no one
imagined before and you hear
you see this whirl of dust as if he or
she has ducked behind the next curtain
giggling
uh see though that's not the the
metaphor that one of these um
strong atheists would use right
um i i i i think that there
is um theological import and
and implication to the fact that we're
the kind of people
who can subsidize
not only elites to do this search
but also demand and lure those elites
online into pbs shows to share
it eagerly with a
bemused amused and and and
uh and highly empowered um
community of amateur scientist citizens
so having said that let me say that i
participated in this a little bit i
i offered a couple of insights that
roger penrose
uh included in his uh conformal mapping
cosmology which i think is is one of the
coolest things
if you want to um
my my recent lamented uh dear departed
friend
freeman dyson um i
awarded him the prize of the great
theologian of the 20th century because
he won the debate
with frank tipler yes over
what the universe would be like and
freeman
thought that it would expand forever and
he gave us the theology of how
super advanced beings might try to
endure
after even all the protons have decayed
frank tipler had this wonderful baroque
incredibly amusing and frustrating book
called the physics of immortality
that talked about what might happen in
the last million years
if the expansion of the universe slowed
down because of gravity and then came
together in the big crunch
and our distant distant descendants
became effectively god and because they
could collect all the infrared rays that
you have omitted when you
when you've laid in a blanket outside at
night
they know you and they resurrect you at
the
at the end of time what an amazing
amazing wonderful and if it weren't true
it ought to be and now roger comes and
he says
stop you're both right it's going to be
expanding forever
the pot the protons and electrons
everything will decay
and when the last proton decays
it all simply becomes a big bang
yes it's very poetic it has a uh some
some overtones of judeo-christianity
perhaps as well
and i think there are some beautiful
aspects of it what
intrigues me so much is the uh was the
comity
that i observed for most of these
debates there was some pugilism
that came in and as i said you know they
don't say
that physicists are going toe to toe uh
for nothing
huh that's a good one right i just lost
a toenail last night oh no
i'm so sorry we won't go toe to toe nail
then all right
but uh but these these folks have widely
disparate
you know conjectures and you know in
some sense there can be only one
it's not as if you know one is newtonian
talking about the
you know low low mass limit of a higher
dimensional higher
um you know encompassing field theory
such as einstein's field theory
it's it's that one has you know field
theory einstein's field theory
and the other one has uh you know
cellular automata as steven does you
know
as a fundamental generating force so i
wonder you know how how do we reconcile
this in the
scientific method you've written about
this recently as well and i'll put a
link to that
how how how is it possible that so many
different
things can flourish or are we being too
cometis accommodating however you will
correct
me um why do we seek this when or should
we seek
a sense of conciliance or should we
instead be
more suited up for intellectual battle
because there can be only one or
well other than your um
your reference to the movie highlander
um you can be only one you like that
movie because there are
movies i know you have different that
movie violated the third movie syndrome
of the 80s and 90s where it was was the
third movie that
was crap it was crap yeah that one that
one went straight to number two
um in all ways but the um
no what has happened very often is
that we find that two very good theories
turn out to be different versions of the
same thing
mathematical presentations some guy
comes along and says
oh did you know that this completely
different math
maps directly onto uh
onto this other map i actually did that
for my master's dissertation in the
theory of polarized light
showing that these two different models
were essentially the same thing
yes um so that can happen
uh and then you can have winners and
losers and if you're
losing theory was really really
cool then you don't lose your tenure
i mean you you don't lose your respect i
just i just gave an example of that
frank tipler it was it was honored and
and and people didn't talk about his
book
i'm talking about his book 30 years
later because it
was a fantastic science fiction novel
um let me put it this way
um this whole left right thing has
another insanity
and that is that um the right
supposedly declares the virtues of
competition
but hates regulation because it
interferes with competition
the left is suspicious of the word
competition and would like everybody to
cooperate
that's a gross oversimplification and
but to the extent people believe it it's
it's it's
treason to what made everything work for
us and that is
regulated competition because if you
look across those 6
000 years of pyramidal cultures cheating
abounded
and you don't get the creativity
of competition if those on top are
cheating
what adam smith talked about and
fdr and uh and his cousin teddy
roosevelt and so on
was how to regulate away the cheating
so that we get the benefits of
competition
now there are five great arenas in which
we've learned how to do this
uh one is uh markets democracy both of
them being deliberately poisoned now but
but
we have proved that you can do that you
can have regulated competition and those
that
create vast wealth uh justice courts
science is regulated by holding each
other accountable
yes and adversarial and adversaries
that's right it's adversarial
i point out that this this notion that
scientists are these
unique lemmings following the same
paradigm
climate change we all have to do the
same thing
it's ridiculous scientists are the most
competitive humans our species
ever created and i'm looking at one
right now
and and uh but but we don't need a lot
of regulation because
we have an ultimate arbiter an ultimate
referee
called objective reality i mean he's
going to tell us sooner or later which
of us is right
right and that leaves the fifth arena
which
proves the case because it's sports try
to imagine
a sporting league that removed all
regulation
for one saturday including the rules
against murder
it was dissolved in violence and death
the purge right and that would be the
end of the sporting league
uh look at rollerball uh they they tried
that and roll around
murder so so what i'm trying to get at
is
that competition
is the wellspring of
creativity but it's always ruined by
cheating unless it's regulated by
something now you were talking about
competition between these different
theories
of everything well objective reality
supposedly
is going to be the arbiter and so we can
remain
kind of courteous to each other kind of
um
um collegial as we eviscerate each
other's theories and criticize
each other's theories and use that
criticism to
make our theories better but
what you alluded to is very important
we are now entering territory where what
becomes
modelable and plausible
includes a lot of things that can never
be tested
and max tegmark and your other guests
were talking about that last time on
your show
on the theory of everything is does
everything have to be popparian
after carl popper does everything have
to be testable
and as a science fiction author
who's also a scientist i know there are
realms
in which these things overlap and we are
just
not going to be able to test them but we
can continue to develop
a sense of plausibility
and if we look forward to you know
future debates i'm curious as to
what would be stimulating in your mind
what other kinds of big
mysteries we kind of cover the
fundamental laws of nature in these and
i've had interviews with stephen and
wolfram and eric weinstein i'll put
links to it and the podcast as well
but and others critics such as sabine
hassenfelder who was a guest who's
extremely
uh extremely critical of the both the
pursuit
of what you called earlier kind of the
tenure
uh getter papers you know the elegant
beautiful
uh irresis resplendent theories
as a guideline as a guidepost to uh
to the future of physics she's actually
quite negative pessimistic curmudgeonly
about it and she
says as much even to the extent of not
thinking it's warranted to build a
future high energy physics
particle collider such as the future
circular collider
which would have a price tag of 20
billion euros or dollars
they're about the same nowadays but
maybe maybe less so in the future
and by the way whenever you hear a
number like that people listening out
there if somebody comes to you
asks you to write a check for a particle
accelerator i just had a philanthropist
ask me
to speculate on a very interesting
experiment what had a price tag of
several million dollars and i said to
this person i said uh and how much is it
going to be to operate this thing
because you don't you don't build a
nuclear-powered submarine just to have
it sit there right so these things that
cost 20 nuclear-powered submarines
such as the future circular collider
sheets claims we could use it for other
things such as what you've tet what
you've spoken about
climate change if you were more of a
king than you are
in your realm and you could uh set the
budgets for physics
as a function of gdp uh where would it
where would it sit
and then would you fund things that have
no guarantee of paying out
well if i were the um family friend
whispering
in benjamin's ear in the graduate um
instead of plastics i would say cosmic
rays
i mean after all um
we're never going to make an accelerator
more powerful
than a great many uh cosmic rays which
we see
piling into our atmosphere or passing
through our spacecraft all the time now
they are diffuse
but i would put money into finding ways
of making detector systems
that are very very large that can be in
space
and that can um pick up
um and and that can
analyze these cosmic rays that are
so vastly more powerful than anything we
would ever make
now the argument for the collider is
that we can
um make 7 8 9 10 orders of magnitude
more
of these high energy particles uh and
refine them so that we know exactly what
they were before they collided
um and that's that's an argument
but um i also see the argument to um
trying to repair our civilization
um and giving that top priority i'm wary
of the uh left's
notion that uh it's it's a zero-sum game
um
but there are times when the money is
that big
that it is taking things away uh
so it's not totally positive some and by
the way
that is the most important concept of
our civilization and that is the notion
of the positive sum game
um yes those five arenas were set up
in order to try to create competition
so that there are winners and losers but
everybody's getting
getting more so you know my aim
in the marketplace or in science is to
um
is to be victorious over you while we
both win
uh and and that's kind of game actually
it's actually amazing that human beings
are capable of even understanding it
because almost all of our ancestry from
the caves to the tribes to the
to the empires was all
zero sum in order to win you had to make
someone else lose
so the notion that we are capable of
positive sum
and and more than half of americans poll
as being able to understand the basic
idea
of positive sum games i think that's
remarkable
yeah i agree uh david i'm running
short on time i have to interview
several more geniuses like yourself
uh i always like this i want to do it
more regularly than once a month
uh or then once every four months uh
let's try to do it monthly as i
originally
had hoped if you will accommodate it i'm
happy to
and i want to raise a glass of whatever
we've got
in honor of our dear friend andy andy
friedman
um you were talking about the theory of
everything in the multiverse
well we had we were the three
physicists it's not that often i get to
wear that hat
so andy andy was was brilliant and
wonderful
and one of the sweetest and and he and
his dear wife were probably the cutest
couple i have
seen outside they are and i have good
news for you as final paper
uh which is a test of lorenzen variance
violation
using distant cosmological objects a
project that he pioneered stewarded led
through
analysis all the ways and opposite ends
of the universe
yes uh he uh he that paper we just
received word that the uh has been
accepted for publication
in physics review d which is a hugely
high impact journal
i'm planning to do a special podcast
tribute to him uh
and maybe also speak about that paper in
particular because it's uh it's a tour
de force it was a masterpiece
the cosmos has lost one of its greatest
luminaries and uh
i'm emotional thinking about it it's
been only a month since we lost him
recording this in in august august 12th
margaret burbidge's
birthday would have been 101 years old
and uh
unfortunately andy uh did not come close
to that so
we miss him we miss margaret too we love
you david thank you so much
be well stay well let's talk again very
soon
all right take care brian best of luck